hi there steve kaufman here today i want
to talk about mistakes
we all make mistakes some people are
upset
when they make mistakes i'm not and i
want to go into some detail on how we
can take advantage of this
the mistakes that we make to do better
in our language learning
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
you can click on the bell to get
notifications and by all means join me
at link
where i learn languages so
you know we cannot understand when
things are said
or we cannot understand when we read
because we didn't quite
hear it properly or we've forgotten the
word or we don't know the word
so there are all kinds of ways that we
can simply not understand but that's not
a mistake
there's no anxiety there there's only
anxiety
if you don't understand when you're in a
conversation in other words
somebody says something to you and you
don't understand what they're saying
so then you can't reply you can't say
anything
there there's anxiety but if you are
engaged in input activities such as
listening and reading
certainly i can tolerate a lot of
vagueness
ambiguity misunderstanding it really
doesn't bother me
because i know that through continuing
my
input activities i will gradually see
things more clearly
understand things more clearly there's
no great pressure on me
however as soon as you start speaking
with someone
things change as i said if you don't
understand what they're saying
that's quite intimidating in fact to me
that's the most intimidating thing
when i don't understand what people are
saying i can't even attempt to reply
however there's also the problem when
you say something and you say it wrong
you use the wrong word you use the wrong
tense you use the wrong form of the verb
or the noun
whatever it might be or or the structure
the phrasing is incorrect
and so you're conscious or you might
pronounce poorly and you're conscious of
the difficulty that you have
sometimes you can watch a video or
listen to an audio of yourself
and you will notice mistakes that you
made that maybe you weren't aware of
while you were
engaged in the conversation and that's
often very useful
because then you can really then zoom in
on those areas and try to improve
or you know pay attention to them when
you next come across them in
in listening and reading but
it is a bit unsettling there's a fear
people don't want to make mistakes
when we study at school we make mistakes
on our little test
and so we get marked down for them and
so we sort of develop this habit this
sense that mistakes are bad
uh if i get a test at school and i go 10
out of 10 i'm good
if i go 5 out of 10 i'm bad but the
reality is
at least in my experience is that i can
get something right one time and wrong
the next time
wrong the first time and write the next
time
it depends what the brain is doing at
the moment sometimes it remembers it
correctly and
sometimes it doesn't and so i think it's
not
a good thing to train ourselves to think
of mistakes as
bad things to me a mistake is an
opportunity to improve
you make a mistake very often you're
aware that you made a mistake
you're either aware that you might be
aware of what the correct
usage was or you might simply not be
sure what the correct usage is
and so you are bothered by that
that being bothered by mistakes
potential or
actual mistakes drives that curiosity
that
desire to focus in on that structure
that use of words or whatever
and to get better at it and so to that
extent mistakes
are a sign that we are pushing ourselves
outside of our comfort zone
it's an opportunity to become aware of
the gaps
we have in what we have learned
it is a very positive thing in the
process of learning a language
that's why i'm not a fan of tests there
are people who can score well on tests
who can
get certain fine points of grammar
correctly but
cannot communicate properly don't
understand very well
i think if you throw yourself into the
idea of communicating
for the sake of communicating and
gradually building up your comprehension
building up your vocabulary building up
your ability to marshal
the words uh produce
the words in the correct sort of usage
pattern
all of which the brain will gradually do
the brain will not
be able to remember a specific rule uh
if you try to force it to remember you
know these specific
usage patterns but the brain will
gradually get more and more used to
these patterns
possibly reminded by a grammar a grammar
explanation
and very often reminded by the fact that
you got it wrong
and so the the fact that you got it
wrong triggers
this desire to get closer to what that
usage is
now there are people who continue to
make the same mistakes over and over
again
and i think that's a lack of of
attentiveness to the language
you have to want to notice what's
happening in the language so
i definitely do recommend recording say
a conversation or doing a video even in
a foreign language and then listening to
it
and see seeing if you can pick out your
own mistakes
and even if you pick them out and you
look up the rule or you pay attention to
it
that doesn't mean you're going to get it
right the next time there is no
immediate correction teachers may think
that they can correct you and that
therefore you'll get it right
that has never been my experience when i
taught english
say as a tutor at link
i could correct the person three four
times they would still make the same
mistake
when i go through my tutors reports
at link i'll see that i get the same
correction from them the same phrase or
word that i used wrong i use it wrong
week after week but eventually i get it
right so
it doesn't bother me that because my
whole the whole learning process
is a continuing a continuum of
knowing less understanding less making
more mistakes
and gradually understanding more having
more words
and making fewer mistakes so at a given
point in time
that i'm making a lot of mistakes that's
an indication that i'm learning you know
if i were to limit myself to a very
narrow range of words
and only ever talk about the weather or
things that i'm comfortable
uh talking about where i have got a sort
of a routine that i know
is more or less correct that's not
learning the language
it's only when i push myself into
you know a ever you know broader uh
range of subject matter and try to
express my views
on those things that i'm learning and of
course
inevitably if i do that i'm going to
make more mistakes
so mistakes are valuable mistakes are an
indication that you're pushing yourself
beyond the
comfort of a limited range of subject
matter
if you're paying attention to what
you're saying paying attention to what
the native speaker
is saying then you're able to then focus
in on these areas when you are listening
and reading
and all of this is part of the gradual
process of improving yourself
and as i have said often in quoting
manfred spitzer
the brain cannot do otherwise than learn
if you expose the brain to the patterns
of the language
you expose the brain to trying to say
things and getting them wrong
and then reminding yourself of what the
correct usage was
and you keep keep on doing these things
the brain will gradually develop
patterns for using the language that are
more and more correct
more and more uh based on the standard
usage of what you've been listening to
and what you've been hearing people say
but that process of learning
is a slow process it's not because you
are taught something that you're going
to get it right
so we need to have patience we need to
be indulgent with ourselves
we need to recognize mistakes for what
they are valuable
mind milestones as we progress
in a language so there you have it
that's my take on mistakes
and leave you with a couple of videos
that might
reinforce this message thanks for
listening bye for now